hi Jimmy Vivino here with the new number
two
[Music]
for all you old folks you know what that
references to the prisoner tell me who
everybody is here first let's start down
down there are the base hey Frank I play
drums pull other things John more other
things
Jeremy play guitar I'm Dee right does
everybody play a lot of different
instruments here yeah everyone plays
everything so it's one of those things
where we just choose for what track
who's playing one on into playing piano
and chaos or guitar and chaos and he's
playing strings and it is it's just yeah
or controlled chaos is okay sometimes
it's control it's called now when bands
got together in the old days in the old
days they they you know played out and
played their music and then they
recorded it and it seems today that the
process has changed of course Beatles
changed that process by the studio
becoming you know part of the band and
then having to learn what you did in the
studio I mean I imagine that's how it
goes today that's quite hard with us I
mean yeah we sometimes it goes one way
sometimes it goes the other way and it's
really they see the reverse engineering
or you go oh that's good and then you've
made a record you see late you know we
have to learn how yeah even if you make
it when you're making it with everyone
there you still then have to go back and
learn how to play by the time you finish
mixing it you forgotten what you were
doing and then you have to go and
remember it this is about this record
fear of missing out it's great it comes
with where like it's been on your in
your collection for a long time been
sitting in that or you know when we
first made it we originally designed it
for but I not as I made it just five
songs or five songs yeah and I think a
lot of thought went into what it was
gonna be like when you turn the record
over you know no right I'm making a rest
sure there's the break yeah because
otherwise you just get 25 songs doing
around yeah
don't you find song sequencing is way
more poorly more good and if he helps us
to write the record I think by thinking
about it like that I mean it to me this
is the old way of doing I love it but
there's something exciting to me and my
old miss of downloading getting it like
that it's good because this really turns
me on to some new music which I need to
hear and you know it's it's good to know
that everything's not retro and it's not
necessary because you always go back and
listen to the old records anyway and to
try and beat old records it's crazy yeah
it's like man can you record and make it
something fun this is really a mix of
old and new ideas pushing the music
forward it's important and you guys are
doing it and I love that about it it's
really a good record well thanks a lot
yeah all right I'll see you on the
band's that's right yeah bye
[Music]